having felt the pain that sharp in a
while city is mourning at a family's
morning where we're all morning it seems
like a bad thing a bad dream
she just one wake up from the nightmare
former NBA stars overwhelmed with grief
over the death of Kobe Bryant who died
Sunday alongside his daughter Gianna and
seven others after a helicopter crash in
Calabasas California those are the birds
can't get back now wish I could just say
something to him but no one is missing
Kobe more right now than his wife
Vanessa a source who's friends with the
Bryant family tells ET that Vanessa is
completely shocked and heartbroken but
adds that she's staying strong in front
of their kids 17 year old Natalya three
year old Bianca and seven month-old
Capri good night great date night you
guys get to go home down relax yeah we
know you know really good a chance to
really kick it without the kids man said
we might I might go out hang out for a
little bit
Vanessa married Kobe when she was just
18 years old and the source explained
she never expected to live her life
without him right now the source says
vanessa is surrounded by her family and
friends but she feels almost numb to
everything yeah that's part of the deal
make each other better right our source
says Vanessa appreciates the outpouring
of love she and her family have received
and she will respond when she's ready
right now she's taking time to be with
her girls while the Bryant family
grieves in private fans around the world
are paying tribute to Kobe's life and
legacy following a touching tribute
during the Grammys et has confirmed that
Kobe will also be acknowledged during
the 20 2000 ceremony on February 9th
what would it mean to hold this Oscar up
and be the first NBA player to win it I
you know I got to say it's a is even
more special to me than
because you know as a kid I dreamed of
winning championships you know when you
dream of doing something and you
accomplished it like I've seen that
happen since the age of two never in my
wildest dreams and I thought we've ever
been here at the Oscar would be
nominated for an Oscar that's insane
you'll recall Kobe won Oscar gold in
2018 for Best Animated Short Film for
deer basketball et spoke with him just
months after his big win
what's banner Oscar or an NBA
championship ring an Oscar man yeah no
win championships okay all right that's
that somewhat in the realm of
possibility
right when you with your friends yeah 10
years old that's what my friends say I'm
going with our Oscar I mean
[Music]
you